Kim Kardashian breaks her silence about
Khloe and Kanye plus Janelle Monae just
drop some fire it is new music Friday
TGIF my people is Friday and the ladies
are taking over stick around because
Janelle Monae Jennifer Lopez and
scissors are all featured on you music
Friday but first Kim Kardashian stopped
by Ellen and did not hold back about her
sister Khloe's predicament with baby
daddy Tristan Thompson that's right Kim
spilled the tea on her initial reaction
to Tristan's alleged trifling ways and
while she said what I think we're all
thinking here's a sneak peek like I
don't even know how to describe it
besides it's just so plain yeah like
it's I yeah we really were rooting for
Khloe and we still are you know she's
she's so strong and she's doing the best
that she can it's a really sad situation
all over him clearly he's got her
sisters back in she's not wrong
but she also takes the high road telling
Ellen that tomato rule with her brother
Rob that if there's children involved
she's not gonna talk too much trash but
now you didn't think Kim was gonna pop
up on Ellen and not also address Kanye's
tweets did you I mean I hear him say all
these things in the house just about I
think what he was saying about really
that everything he was talking about
clarity and he always talks about how we
should not have our phones first thing
in the morning and in the house when
with the kids let's not have our phone
just it's our rule that we really try to
live by
so I think he was talking about
cleansing something tells me she has a
lot more to say on that the full
interview is going down Monday on Ellen
now as you guys know or maybe not Kanye
has met made headlines all week for his
controversial tweets and it's even got
his famous friends fired up if you
haven't been following it all started
when Yeezy
basically tweeted his support for Donald
Trump which has since turned into a love
fest between the rapper and the
president the Kanye spelled John Legend
then texted him privately saying I hope
you'll reconsider reminding yay
what powerful his platform is well Kanye
responded to him claiming John was
trying to
manipulate his freethought by bringing
up his fans and his legacy now how do I
know all this well
Kanye of course shared their texts on
Twitter if you're wondering what John
thought about all of this he called into
hot 97 in New York and shared his
reaction with the radio host Ebro I was
shocked when it happened but then I was
like well I'm proud of what I said it
could be it can't be that bad you know
at least I didn't say anything that I
didn't want other people to know that I
thought that's right hand uh and so I
felt like I'm not mad that people saw it
because at least they know where I'm
coming from and and so I didn't actually
mind it after I thought about it for a
second but but you know what it wasn't
all bad blood between the lifelong
friends Kanye also promoted Jon's new
single which is what I think all of this
is guys
Kanye's got himself to promote new music
new Yeezy line but here's the thing none
of this is new Kanye has been like this
as long as he's been in the cultural
zeitgeist but now see chance the rapper
though got caught up in this after he
was trying to cut his mentor Kanye some
slack by tweeting black people don't
have to be Democrats while Trump took
that as a sign of support tweeted his
praise to chant and today chants issued
a statement saying that his comments
were poorly time and are not an
endorsement Lord it's a mess as chants
said in that lengthy post that's why
it's probably wiser to not tweet and
just call your friend and if your friend
is Kanye you called don't text
alright guys but let's bring the posi
vibes back because it is Friday and
we've got some new music to talk about
Janelle Monae dropped her new album
dirty computer and where do I even begin
this is a piece of art in every way
there's so many good songs on this balm
and hit you with one of my favorites
it's an album cut I got the juice
featuring Pharrell Williams it doesn't
even have a visual yet but you guys it's
about
[Music]
right genell's latest work comes after
the singer came out as pansexual she
opened up to Rolling Stone magazine
about her sexuality saying she's been in
relationships with both men and women
and considers herself to be a free ass
mother and get your life Janelle are you
guys moving on to another queen
miss Jenny from the block looked far
from it at last night's Latin Billboard
Awards in Vegas that Maine right here is
about 50 inches long I mean she served
us hair goals body goals Peck even life
goals the video for her latest Spanish
single Elle and Neil is here and it's
real regal
[Music]
ah I love that woman damned
and finally scissor also released a new
music video for it doves in the wind
going toe-to-toe with Kendrick Lamar and
a kungfu match
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah so you guys have it some new music
vibes to jumpstart your weekend as
always thanks for watching and hanging
out with me this week we'll be back on
Monday until then hit subscribe and yada
yada yada you know the deal enjoy your
weekend